on ouvre une page justice avec ce
verdict tombé en fin d'après-midi dans
le procès aux assises de cette
octogénaire dont nous vous parlions en
début de semaine les jurés ont
finalement décidé de le condamner à 8
ans de prison en 2020 après 63 ans de
mariage il avait tué son épouse atteinte
de la maladie d'Alzheimer de cette coup
de crosse de fusil sur le crâne sur
place au tribunal de Tours on retrouve
Faustine Luneau
le verdict est tombé après deux heures
de délibéré la Cour a reconnu
Pierre-Olivier coupable et la condamné à
8 années d'emprisonnement dans la
matinée après une heure de réquisitoire
l'avocat général avait requis 10 années
de prison ferme une peine pas déplusée
vers selon lui au vu de la gravité des
faits mais qui prenait en compte la
personnalité et là j'avançais de
l'accusé les avocats de Monsieur Olivier
eux avaient simplement demandé à ce que
leurs clients ne finissent pas séjour en
prison puisqu'il est âgé de 88 ans je
cite il y a une différence entre ce
qu'il a fait et ce qu'il souhaitait
faire on plaider ses avocats appelant à
juger d'abord l'homme avant les faits
pour moi la place de Monsieur Olivier
n'est pas du tout en détention la place
de Monsieur Olivier est dehors Monsieur
Olivier a toujours soutenu qu'il
s'agissait d'un acte d'amour et on en a
convaincu la deuxième chose c'est que
c'était l'acte d'un aidant totalement
épuisé démuni qui avait demandé à 24
prises de l'aide il n'a jamais obtenu
cette aide
il a déjà exécuté deux ans et 8 mois de
détention provisoire ce qui équivaut à
peu près un peu plus de 3 ans et demi en
détention si on fait un accord de la
remise de peine
notre but c'est son but simplement qu'il
rentre chez lui qu'il retrouve à une
partie de sa vie
rappelons que Pierre-Olivier était jugé
pour avoir tué son épouse atteinte
d'Alzheimer en mai 2020 un suicide
commun raté selon lui il encourait entre
deux ans de prison et la perpétuité à
l'annonce de sa condamnation l'accusé
qui avait reconnu l'effet est resté
neutre avant la délibération il avait
prononcé quelques mots je cite je me
suis condamnée moi-même à perpétuité à
ne plus revoir ma femme